Get ready with me to go to our Omas.
I'm gonna be walking you through some of my makeup.
This is my favorite lip color.
This the new confidante by L'oreal.
I've really been getting into gloss,
so this is the laritzy gloss,
and the color is mauve.
I really like how this adds a lot of shine to my lips.
I don't know. I used to never use gloss,
but now I do.
I obviously had a bit of my makeup done before filming,
so I'm just doing my eyes and lips.
And now I am going in with a nude color.
Pinkish nude color for the base of my eyeshadow.
This palette is discontinued,
unfortunately.
And now I am going in with the crease color.
This is a Mavi pink dusty rose kind of color.
I just really like pink tones on my eyes.
I'm not sure why.
I know I read somewhere that pink and red really enhances green eyes,
so I'm guessing that is why.
I'm now going in to do my eyebrows.
I'm not the best at eyebrows,
but I do like the L'oreal blonde shade.
Gotta curl those lashes.
I was not born with amazing lashes,
so I definitely have to do that.
And then I'm using the Tarte mascara.
I got this sample a while ago,
and I really like it.
I'm now pulling my hair down just seeing what I'm working with.
I had a blowout,
so I am kind of good.
For a couple days,
but I'm just fluffing it up.
I love just a nice, freshly done blowout dress of the day.
I will tag the company
and my favorite perfume
you guys know born lovely by Sarah Jessica Parker.
Just so sweet.
And this is a new pocketbook I got.
I'm obsessed with mini purses,
you guys. I will be tagging the brand as well.
I love the purple shade for summer.
These earrings are from the exact same company that the purse is.
Again, I will tag it.
And these are just some cute gold earrings with floral details.
We have an hour and a half road trip to Omas,
so we are excited to get on the road and get going.
When I be the papa, you can be
the mom.
We are doing a cookout.
I am prepping the fruit.
This is just some pineapple.
And I'm wearing my favorite apron.
I will tag the company of this apron as well.
She makes the most beautiful aprons ever.
Husband is in charge of grill duty.
I am searing some onions for our burgers.
Does anybody else put a paper towel with
ice on top of the salad to keep it cold?
Because my Alma does this, and now I do.
Setting the table.
Love the blue and yellow.
And now we are cutting the ribs.
We are so hungry.
Cannot wait to devour this food.
And to end the day,
some ice cream,
fruit, and coffee.